peter helm ein kollege ist jetzt bei mir
er war den ganzen tag auf den straßen
von berlin unterwegs guten morgen peter
lasst uns als erstes mal über die bilder
sprechen die wir jetzt gerade gesehen
haben die verhaftung von attila hildmann
wie wir überhaupt die stimmung gestern
sie schien sehr schnell zu kippen von
fröhlich bis hin zu aggressiv bis hin zu
festnahmen
das ist richtig das ging im prinzip von
stadtteil zu stadtteil von straße zu
straße wo sich eben die jeweiligen
demonstrationsgruppen versammelt haben
das war sehr bunt in anführungsstrichen
also in einer straße wurde zum beispiel
von mehreren hundert demonstranten das
vaterunser gebetet
50 meter weiter schwenkten
rechtsradikale reichs flaggen identität
marschierten dort mit neo nazi symbolen
durch die straßen und 50 meter weiter
waren familien mit ihren kindern dort
und in diesem gemenge lage in dieser in
dieser teilweise wirren zusammensetzung
war eben auch vor dieser russischen
botschaft kam es da eben auch zu diesen
gewalttätigen auseinandersetzung mit
flaschenwürfen gegen die die polizisten
gegen die beamten
es flogen steine und im zuge dessen ist
eben auch dieser
verschwörungstheoretiker nummer eins
attila hildmann verhaftet worden
das dumme an dieser sache ist wenn man
das so sagen darf das sind bilder
gebraucht er das ist das was im prinzip
quasi als märtyrer
darstellt was ihnen quasi noch höher
hebt in seiner community in seiner
kruden gesellschaft in der er sich da
umgibt und ja er verstößt natürlich
dagegen aber letzten endes ist es so es
gefällt ihm und es hebt ihn höher und es
ab sentiert ihn noch mehr von der
sogenannten schlimmen gesellschaft in
der wir leben also eigentlich pr in
eigener sache die er dort betrieben hat
ich will auch noch einmal zu sprechen
kommen auf den ja schon in höhepunkt des
gestrigen tages die versuchte stimmung
des reichstags du warst da mittendrin
wie hast du das erlebt wie war dort die
stimmung wie ist die polizei vorgegangen
und was haben die demonstranten machen
naja die demonstranten sind durchbrochen
haben diese gitter durchbrochen das war
ja vorhin schon erwähnt fast zu erwarten
es gab im vorfeld ankündigung auf einer
bühne
dort ist eben auch attila hildmann
aufgetreten andere mitstreiter die
gemengen lage dort vor dem reichstag das
waren auch rechtsradikale das waren auch
fahnen schwenkenden neonazis die im
prinzip auch keinen zweifel daran
gelassen haben weswegen sie nach berlin
gekommen sind dort ging es nicht um
kroner regeln um die sachliche
diskussion der ereignisse sondern es
ging im prinzip darum quasi das symbol
von deutschland von berlin den deutschen
reichstag zu kopieren
dass die polizei das dann relativ
ordentlich in den griff gekriegt hat war
dann der der masse zu verdanken der
beamten es ist glimpflich abgelaufen
dann im nachhinein hat sie dann einen
korridor gezogen das ihm keiner mehr
rein kommt sie sind dann vorgegangen und
haben dann die rest demonstranten nach
außen getrieben
aber die symbolik ist eine katastrophe
das ist überhaupt so weit kommt dass
sich eben neonazis und mit
reichskriegsflagge vor den deutschen
reichstag versammelt
das ist eben das beschämende eigentlich
auch das hat dann mit
demonstrationsrecht dann auch nicht mehr
viel zu tun
das ist mal über die demonstranten
sprechen wie hast du die wahrgenommen
werden immer wieder versucht diesen mix
an menschen zu analysieren vom
verschwörungstheoretiker normalen
bürgern rechtsradikalen wie weil da die
stimmung und was für menschen waren das
das ist eben das schwieriger dass das
müsste eigentlich ein psychologe
erklären und ein soziologe
es ist natürlich wenn ich auf eine
demonstration gegen mein gutes recht ist
muss sich aber wissen mit wem ich damals
ihre und sagen wir mal so die die
aversion gegen rechtsradikale ist da
überhaupt nicht artikuliert worden also
diese normalen familien und der normale
bürger ist da seite an seite friedlich
mit erkennbar verfassungsfeindlichen
rechtsradikalen seit' an seit' gegangen
und da hat es auch keine abgrenzung
gegeben im gegenteil die abgrenzung hat
gegenüber dem staat stattgefunden
gegenüber den medien gegenüber der
polizei gegenüber menschen die eine
maske getragen haben wir wie
journalisten eben auch als die beamten
da hat man einen gemeinsamen feind und
in dieser gemengelage einen gemeinsamen
feind zu haben ist man eben auch bereit
mit diesen extremen gruppierungen
mitzumarschieren natürlich waren da
normale bürger darunter ganz normal die
meisten es war auch meistens friedlich
alles aber man muss wissen wenn man auf
so eine demonstration demonstrations-
geht mit wem man damit marschiert und da
muss man sich auch die kritik im
nachhinein gefallen lassen